[Applause]
Ronna Ayub is a journalist in India
whose work has exposed government
corruption and human rights violations
and over the years she's gotten used to
vitriol and controversy around her work
but none of it could have prepared her
for she faced in April 2018 she was
sitting in a cafe with a friend when she
first saw it a two minute twenty second
video of her engaged in a sex act as she
couldn't believe her eyes she had never
made a sex video but unfortunately
thousands upon thousands of people would
believe it was her I interviewed miss
Ayub about three months ago in
connection with my book on sexual
privacy I'm a law professor lawyer and
civil rights advocate so it was
incredibly frustrating knowing that
right now law could do very little to
help her and as we talked she explained
that she should have seen the fake sex
video coming she said after all sex is
so often used to demean and to shame
women especially minority women and
especially minority woman who dare to
challenge powerful men as she had in her
work
the fake sex video went viral in 48
hours all of her online accounts were
flooded with screenshots of the video
with graphic rape and death threats and
with slurs about her Muslim faith online
posts suggested that she was available
for sex and she was doxed which means
that her home address and her cell phone
number was spread across the internet
the video was shared more than 40,000
times now when someone is targeted with
this kind of cyber mob attack
the harm is profound Ronna Ayub life was
turned upside down for weeks she could
hardly eat or speak she stopped writing
and closed all of her social media
accounts which is you know a tough thing
to do when you're a journalist and she
was afraid to go outside her family's
home what if the posters make good on
their threats the UN Council on Human
Rights confirmed that she wasn't being
crazy it issued a public statement
saying that they were worried about her
safety
what Rana Ayub faced was a deep fake
machine learning technology that
manipulates or fabricates audio and
video recordings to show people doing
and saying things that they never did
her said deep fakes appear authentic and
realistic but they're not they're total
falsehoods although the technology is
still developing in its sophistication
it is widely available now the most
recent attention to deep fakes arose as
so many things do online with
pornography in early 2018 someone posted
a tool on reddit to allow users to
insert faces into porn videos and what
followed was a cascade of fake porn
videos featuring people's favorite
female celebrities and today you can go
on YouTube and pull up countless
tutorials with step-by-step instructions
on how to make a deep fake on your
desktop application and soon we may be
even able to make them on our cell
phones now it's the interaction of some
of our most basic human frailties and
network tools that can turn deep fakes
into weapons so let me explain as human
beings we have a visceral reaction to
audio and video we believe they're true
on the notion that of course you can
believe what your eyes and ears are
telling you and it's that mechanism that
might undermine our shared sense of
reality although we believe deep fakes
to be truth and
and we're attracted to the salacious the
provocative we tend to believe in to
share information that's negative and
novel and researchers have found that
online hoaxes spread ten times faster
than accurate stories now we're all so
drawn to information that aligns with
our viewpoints psychologists call that
tendency confirmation bias and social
media platforms supercharge that
tendency by allowing us to instantly and
widely share information that accords
with our viewpoints
now deep fakes have the potential to
cause grave individual and societal harm
so imagine a deep fake that shows
American soldiers in Afghanistan burning
a Koran you can imagine that that deep
fake would provoke violence against
those soldiers and what if the very next
day there's another deep fake that drops
that shows a well-known imam based in
London praising the attack on those
soldiers we might see violence and civil
unrest not only in Afghanistan and the
United Kingdom but across the globe and
he might say to me come on Danielle
that's far-fetched but it's not we've
seen falsehoods spread on whatsapp and
other online message services lead to
violence against ethnic minorities and
that was just text imagine if it were
video no deep fakes have the potential
to corrode the trust that we have in
democratic institutions so imagine the
night before an election there's a deep
fake showing one of the major party
candidates gravely sick the deep fake
could tip the election and shake our
sense that elections are legitimate
imagine if the night before an initial
public offering of a major global bank
there was a deep fake showing the bank
CEO drunkenly spout
in conspiracy theories the deep fake
could tank the IPO and worse shake our
sense that financial markets are stable
so deep fakes can exploit and magnify
the deep distrust that we already have
in politicians business leaders and
other influential leaders they find an
audience prime to believe them and the
pursuit of truth is on the line as well
technologists expect that with advances
in AI soon it may be difficult if not
impossible to tell the difference
between a real video and a fake one so
how can the truth emerge in a deep fake
written marketplace of ideas will we
just proceed along the path of least
resistance and believe what we want to
believe truth be damned and not only
might we believe the fakery we might
start disbelieving the truth we've
already seen people invoke the
phenomenon of deep fakes to cast doubt
on real evidence of their wrongdoing
we've heard politicians say of audio of
their disturbing comments come on that's
fake news you can't believe what your
eyes and ears are telling you you know
telling you and it's that risk that
Professor Robert Chesney and I call the
liars dividend the risk that Liars will
invoke deep fakes to escape
accountability for their wrongdoing so
we've got our work cut out for us
there's no doubt about it and we're
gonna need a proactive solution from
tech companies from lawmakers law
enforcers and the media and we're gonna
need a healthy dose of societal
resilience so now we're right now
engaged in a very public conversation
about the responsibilities of tech
companies and my advice to social media
platforms has been to change their Terms
of Service and Community Guidelines
to ban deep fakes that cause harm
now that determination that's gonna
require human judgement and it's
expensive but we need human beings to
look at the content and context of a
deep fake to figure out if it is a
harmful and personation
or instead if it's valuable satire art
or education so now what about the law
law is our educator it teaches us about
what's harmful and what's wrong and it
shapes behavior it deters by punishing
perpetrators and securing remedies for
victims now right now law is not up to
the challenge of deep fakes across the
globe we lack well tailored laws that
are that would be designed to tackle
digital impersonations that invade
sexual privacy the damaged reputations
and that caused emotional distress what
happened to Rana Ayub is increasingly
commonplace yet when she went to law
enforcement in Delhi she was told
nothing could be done and the sad truth
is that the same would be true in the
United States and in Europe so we have a
legal vacuum that needs to be filled my
colleague dr. Marianne Franks and I are
working with US lawmakers to divide
legislation that would ban harmful
digital impersonations that are
tantamount to identity theft and we've
seen similar moves in Iceland the UK and
Australia but of course that's just a
small piece of the regulatory puzzle now
I know law is not a cure-all right it's
a blunt instrument and we've got to use
it wisely it also has some practical
impediments you can't leverage law
against people you can't identify and
find and if a perpetrator lives outside
the country where a victim lives then
you may not be able to insist that the
perpetrator come in to local courts to
face justice and so we're gonna need a
coordinated international response
education has to be part of our response
as well law enforcers are not going to
enforce laws they don't know about and
prefer problems they don't understand in
my research on cyber stalking I found
that law enforcement lacked the training
to understand the laws available to them
and the problem of online abuse and so
often they told victims just turn your
computer off ignore it it'll go away and
we saw that in Rana Ayub case she was
told come on you making such a big deal
about this it's boys being boys
and so we need to pair new legislation
with efforts at training an education
has to be aimed on the media as well
journalists need educating about the
phenomenon of deep fakes
so they don't amplify and spread them
and this is the part where we're all
involved each and every one of us needs
educating we click we share we like and
we don't even think about it
we need to do better we need far better
radar for fakery so as we're working
through these solutions there's going to
be a lot of suffering to go around Rana
Ayub is still wrestling with the fallout
she still doesn't feel free to express
herself on an offline and as she told me
she still feels like there are thousands
of eyes on her naked body even though
intellectually she knows it wasn't her
body and she has frequent panic attacks
especially when someone she doesn't know
tries to take her picture what if
they're gonna make another deep fake she
thinks to herself and for this so for
the sake of individuals like Ron Ayub
and the sake of our democracy we need to
do something right now thank you
you